[Music]
it is a common misconception that the
builders of the pyramids were slaves
forced to work by the king however these
workers were for the most part skilled
builders and craftsmen in the permanent
service of the king the specific numbers
of the workforce needed for the building
of such monuments is difficult to
precisely identify what we do know is
that these men were divided into crews
of peasant conscripts of about 2,000 men
the crews were divided into two gangs
which in turn were divided into five
groups called Saha of 200 men these
groups were themselves divided into ten
divisions of 20 men or maybe 20
divisions of 10 men the different gangs
had names which usually included that of
the reigning king such as Friends of
Khufu and the drunkards of men Caray
these different gangs had different
tasks within the construction of the
pyramid
thanks to expeditions carried out
throughout the 20th century we have
access to the skeletal remains of some
of the pyramid builders and these have
been analyzed in bio archaeological
studies to be able to further gauge how
the health of the pyramid builders
compared to other people living at Giza
contemporaneously various indicators of
health have been compared from these two
populations coming from the western
cemetery for high officials and the
southeast cemetery for workers the
evidence shows that the pyramid workers
died earlier in life than their more
privileged counterparts who were also
living at Giza men died nearly 10 years
earlier and women died roughly 5 years
sooner the female workers from Giza
however exhibit a smaller stature than
their Amarna counterparts standing at
150 point 5 3 centimeters while the
Amarna women were roughly 154
zero two centimeters the laborers at
Giza displays severe changes to their
vertebral bodies the largest part of an
individual vertebra which indicates that
they experienced fairly high levels of
spinal trauma recent evidence from the
Giza Plateau suggests that at least in
the case of Khafre and Menkaure
the workmen were living in permanent
settlements that actually represent some
of the earliest known urban planning in
these workman's villages we find
abundant remains of high quality animals
such as cattle and sheep and goats which
were not normally part of the daily diet
of the commoners in addition the remains
of two bakeries and one hospital were
recovered again pointing to the
high-quality treatment that these
workers received
you